hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that and my guest
today is a remarkable woman who is the
publisher of a remarkable magazine now
the woman in question is Katia Deborah
Ganser who I would like to welcome most
warmly to talking to Germany today
thanks very much for joining us coming
all the way from Bonn and the remarkable
magazine that I mentioned is called
Auden course or ear kisser
more on that intriguing title shortly
but I should and I must first mention
that the magazine has a very special
perspective on the world due to the fact
that it is written exclusively by a team
of authors all of whom have Down
syndrome so it's fascinating stuff I
think catio deborah Gunn said the first
question I suppose is you had the idea
for the magazine as far as I understand
it way back in 1987 at a conference you
attended in Madrid tell us a story
oh it was a great story I was sitting in
a lecture and it was boring so do you
remember sitting in at the University in
the lecture and the light is going away
and there's an overhead projector or and
I was should I sleep I was thinking then
I decided to read the story written on
the overhead projector and it was
handwritten on one page the story of
Robin Hood and the Robin Hood I adored
him as I was a child I read the story
handwritten on one page the whole story
exciting and then it made click I
realized oh a man with Down syndrome
wrote this story he can write he can
explain a very complicated thing on one
page that's great and I was ashamed too
because I realized that for years I had
believed that my colleagues say as they
said people with Down syndrome cannot
read or write why did you believe that I
mean it's fast I was yeah I mean it's
fascinating that you bought into this
prejudice
as if you were working in the field you
hear you'd written your doctoral thesis
yeah on people with you bouncing yeah
yeah yeah
and still you believe that they couldn't
read they couldn't write as many people
still do today yeah that was very
interesting I realized I believed what
someone has written in a book yeah
and this belief was so strong although I
saw someone sitting there writing this
thing in my mind was stronger and I was
shocked because of realizing I'm not the
only person this is going to happen and
I decided to find out how come that this
thing happens like that it's like we
believe people cannot fly yeah and their
wood is the window someone flies and you
say no no that's an exception possible
that's not okay
and so we go on talking and that's
incredible and I decided to work on and
find out more about this kind of thing
happening in my mind and in the mind of
other people and what can I do to get
this lock thing opened and more flexible
there must be some kind of reason that I
am that stubborn in mind yeah tell me
why you were sitting there in the first
place because as we've mentioned you
you'd written your doctoral thesis on
people with Down syndrome why had you
made that choice writing about people
with Down syndrome because I think it
was totally interesting there's
something very special and they are able
to live with 47 chromosomes that's
something it's a miracle this is the
geneticist in use yeah she's a biologist
oh she's a scientist yeah yeah fantastic
okay we'll talk about all of that and
much more yeah you've had your first
impressions there from Cathy Ida Bragg
answer and the magazine or and Costilla
is
and catchers next job is to explain
because I promised at the beginning of
the show that we would do you need to
explain where the title of the magazine
ear case or in course actually comes
from it's interesting all uncaused
around our house we were looking for a
name for the magazine and it wasn't easy
and we were sitting in a cafe and born
outside it was summer and my colleague
Misha L Hager was sitting left on the
left side and he drank coffee and ate an
ice cream with three ice cream balls yes
and he felt Oh life is great and he sat
there and then he decided to kiss me on
the left ear and so all the others they
screamed Oh organ costs means yes and
then he said behind our house means
they're in they're out it goes in one
ear and goes out of the other and then
my colleague on that side she explained
you hear a lot every day and the most
goes in and out like this on only the
important thing stay in mind and that is
an organ course wonderful yeah it's a
wonderful wonderful expression I hope it
you know is adopted more widely in the
German language of their wonderful
medieval world in the whole world you're
very ambitious aren't you sure you stop
at nothing
part of the fact that you are so very
ambitious is when I you know I took his
autumn course yeah here's one of the
magazines yeah
this is what a recent edition it's
called superpowers well a catcher will
tell us a little bit more about that
later or in just a minute but I want to
one thing I just want to look at but is
the I go in here a little bit and you
can see the quality of the magazine it's
often described as a glossy magazine
believe it or not that's quite
interesting and it the quality of the
photography the quality of the layout
these are the absolutely highest
production qualities and that's very
important to you tell me why about 16
years ago as we were a research project
we were at the University and borne all
and course was created in the first two
years of this project we were trying to
find out more how the
world people without Down syndrome look
at people with Down syndrome and how
people with Down syndrome feel living in
this world okay and in the magazine the
person making the photos it's always one
person it's a professional person
interested in looking at my colleagues
and this person with the camera kind of
looks at my team working at the
superpower topic for all the others so
and this person has to work together
with my colleagues they are making the
workshop and writing and so on and has
to bear getting very near and staying
together with them for some time and
that's why we have this kind of quality
of the photos they are not kind of stock
photos made two years ago or something
they are created for this magazine made
by a person contacting us and saying I
want to look at your people all sorts of
different people all sorts of different
professional photographers yeah yeah and
they are curious in finding out what
happens to me if I try and and I'm brave
because many people are afraid of
looking at someone being different and
they say I want to take this challenge
that's interesting and as you've
mentioned we talked about this addition
superpowers yeah and what what they do
on on because it's a very interesting
concept is that each and every magazine
is dedicated to it to a different a
separate theme each time and this one's
superpowers just this is from November 9
2013 so it's a relatively recent
addition there a for each year I should
add just tell us can see what this one
what this one is all about actually we
take half a year for each magazine and
there are two each year okay and here we
have reworked half year trying to find
out what are my abilities
where am I fit what can I do can I help
old ladies cross the road and make them
feel good that's a talent
yes and can I make good coffee can I do
this or that and then we made a workshop
and every one working in this workshop
try to find out what kind of ability do
I want to learn like James Bond
so someone said I want to fly and I need
little wings at my shoes
so we had a kind of mr. Q working with
us and he helped the people get wings at
the shoes or someone said I want to be
able to dive in water and breathe
underwater because that's where I want
to do whatever and then they got a
breathing machine yes like mr. Q yeah he
supports James Bond bomba research and
everything so that was the workshop and
then the photograph I made the photos
after we worked together and one man
this one on the cover said I want
superpowers like a special animal and I
need paintings here and there and then
I've got these powers and so someone had
to paint him exactly the way he wanted
it talking about the the capacities the
qualities that people have on the people
who are on your on your editorial staff
I don't want to generalize necessarily
about people with Down syndrome but I'm
very interested to know whether there is
not some kind of common stylistic
approach that has emerged in the 15
years you've been working on the
magazine I'm not really sure if I
understood the question but I think if I
say I can very often recognize if a text
i read is written by someone with Down
syndrome that's what you mean I was in
Berlin last year and I was in a theater
from another country I don't remember
now but they translated into English and
I read it and after a minute I realized
oh this lady writing that must have
heard down must have down syndrome and
then I asked the team and they said yes
that's true so what what I study biology
I cannot explain but it's something
unexpected it's some charm it is very
powerful it's up to the point
it's a change of perspective all these
things creating of new words and first
my talking let's say about the
grandmother and then talking about
walking down the stairs something
unexpected yes all these kind of things
and you would never dare to write like
that you would be won't be able to do it
and I also want but that is what I have
to go I have to come back to the
magazine again just the way you're
explaining this is precisely did you get
hold of this magazine we've become a
subscriber yeah because this that is
precisely what you get in this magazine
it's also what you get I should just
introduce this book cause we've got to
hear the autumn coast dictionary that
came out to celebrate the 10th
anniversary of the publication yeah so
it's all great stuff very direct very
lots of just unexpected turns of phrase
and very very fascinating now people
with disabilities have all too often
been marginalized and excluded by
society and their capacity to make a
contribution has says-- character did
Braganza long been underestimated but
that is beginning to change and it's
becoming increasing increasingly clear
just how important it is for all of us
to be part of the world of work
it's a nice little reporter cachito
Braganza the I introduced a report by
suggesting and I'm sure it's true yeah
that work is important for all of us
especially because of the recognition
that goes with work yeah you agree yes
but first of all because if I do
something I know my magazine is good
even before someone has seen it yes and
then if someone you when painting a
picture making a photo or writing
something there's a moment you know now
it's perfect
yes and it's good to get a feeling for
this moment
even if baking a cake making a bed yeah
yes everything's very important and
that's what my colleagues are very
talented in they know now it's okay and
I know now the magazine is okay you can
get to print it and then if someone
reads it and says it's fantastic I'm
happy that this person likes it but
actually this feeling is this moment is
before there you know what I mean hey
yeah and then we kind of share what I
experienced and my team the people with
46 chromosomes together with the
colleagues with 47 chromosomes and our
team this is kind of the overdose world
our way of experiencing things and
whatever we share it with the world if
they read this magazine and that's great
it is great and the but you you pay I
know you pay us a small sum for your
content for the contributions to the
contributors yeah but most I'll probably
all of them also have day jobs yes so
what kind of jobs do they have and very
different some work in a cafe some work
in a iton home and at all a home for the
elderly yes or in them in an office or
some work I don't know how you call it
in English in a vac start in a workshop
yeah a lot of things very difficult and
as a house Meister
yeah oh the house Meister that is a very
very German word yeah the the person who
looks after a building and has the
capability
yeah yeah a caretaker yeah you could say
yeah that's interesting they are very
proud of their work it's very important
do the I mean you have an awful lot of
contact to these people some of them I'm
sure have become very close personal
friends do they view themselves as
disabled people no that's a discussion
we just had as someone said I'm disabled
and then I asked him come on do you
think you are disabled why do you say
that he said the doctor said that and I
said okay do you realize the difference
someone else says you are a disabled do
you feel the Sabel no I'm perfect I'm a
good man I'm attractive and so on so
they actually know the other say they
are disabled it's a definition yes
and it really binds people we had a very
sorry to interrupt but it's a they we
had a very interesting guy here on the
show not so long ago called Dagon talk
mark who is a he's a he's a dancer yeah
and he's a dancer and it wasn't even
clear whether he's a dancer because or
despite of the fact that he contracted
polio when he was a very young baby I
think it was eight months old and when
he was here on the show what he said was
we're all disabled in different ways
yeah and it's a little bit you could
almost say it's a platitude but in a way
it's a very important truth mm-hmm
yeah it is yeah every person has got
challenges to try and achieve something
or I cannot move enough this or that I
cannot write properly with the left hand
and so on but it's a question do i
define it as a disability no I don't and
that's why it can work with my
colleagues I'm not interested in
thinking they are disabled and that's it
kind of stops us going on in a very
creative world and living with it not
with each other if you think someone is
disabled it leaves us as a society with
an awful lot to learn and use capacity
sense yeah if someone cannot do
something I help or I ask him do you
want to do it no otherwise let's go on
it it's it doesn't really make sense
you know I'm sure you do how many people
there are in Germany who have bouncing
that don't count that but I would say
about 50,000 50,000 people yeah the
reason I'm asking is and this is this is
an extremely important and very
difficult and controversial matter is
that as you know in Germany like in many
other countries women when they are
pregnant undergo screening procedures
there are different kinds of screening
procedures available and that can
sometimes lead to the parents the father
and the mother together making the
decision to opt for an abortion because
the child has downs syndrome yeah what's
your response to that it's a very
difficult topic
first of all screening is a very
difficult topic whatever kind of
screening but that's another talk
because many people do really don't
understand what's happening there and
it's difficult for society this kind of
thinking to screen but actually I think
if a couple really knows what they are
what information they are asking for and
they know what is Down syndrome and they
decide not to get this child it's their
decision I what I don't like is if
society decides to force people doing
that I expect you to do it that's not
okay if you privately decide after
discussing it with your family I think
we have to respect that
and I will come to you and ask you for
advice no you can't advise someone in
this kind of a you cannot but you can
see if you want to talk with someone
with Down syndrome yeah yeah you want to
talk do you want to talk with parents
because people have got very
old-fashioned ideas of what kind of life
they have with someone with Down
syndrome that this person won't be able
to take the bus or this person won't be
able to write a postcard or the parents
would never be able to have holidays
together anymore and they realize oh
this young couple they've got a life
they have in common they are going to
the cinema yeah they're reading a book
they've got time and this fellow is
going to work and earning his own money
oh come on it's going to be let's take
this baby yeah and I think it's because
many people don't know anyone with
dancing
and that's why they've got this kind of
picture in mind absolutely and of course
people with Down syndrome they don't
just go to the movies they don't just
read books and take the bus they also
make magazines as we've discovered but
we are going to change the subject we've
talked a lot about Kyoto Braganza and
the ordering cost project we're going to
talk now a little bit about background
because Katie spent the first 12 years
of her life living in India which must
have had quite an impact I guess on
she'll tell us about that in a second
and before we do talk about that let's
have a look at the experience of another
woman who grew up in India and now lives
and works here in Germany
and catch a root manchanda there she
says you know she's sort of halfway
between India and Germany where are you
on the on the continuum that's a very I
actually cannot really answer that I'm
kind of in-between I'm here I'm there
I'm living everywhere I've decided
that's not a problem anymore but it's
really challenging me
I feel homesick when I'm here when I see
a mango and I hear the music when I
smell the food when I hear the birds and
I miss the sounds of the trees and the
rain I want to see the monsoon yeah I
would never use an umbrella here and so
on and if I'm there I'm fed up because
the bus comes too late and I'm feel
German let's just say we've got some
photos I the first one I believe is of
you certainly your parents yes or do you
tell us I mean on the right side you see
this woman with a child on the lap
that's me and in the middle of the small
boy in the white chair is my younger
brother he's one-and-a-half years
younger and behind my mother it's my
father
this photo was made in Germany before we
left for India for Goa okay and that's
it Goa is important we'll have a look at
a photo for I think we've got you and
your brother as well yes yeah and while
we're looking at that is that it where's
that that's in Goa that's it I mean Goa
this was you were born in Goa before
independence and before the age of sort
of mass tourism oh yes yes yes I was
born in Germany but we moved to go on
yeah okay and we lived there and it was
a very traditional areas at the
beginning and the tourists and whatever
hippies started coming in the 17th the
end of the 60s and we I realize all
these changes your mother was from
Germany yeah and and she must have told
you about Germany yeah how much when you
came back when you actually finally came
to this place after twelve years in
India how much of a sort of a cultural
shock was it for you we
spoke German together ah in India I was
able to speak a little bit but I wasn't
prepared for anything you can talk a lot
but you you're not prepared the
temperature the way the people look like
I couldn't defer the people because
everyone looked same and the food
jamaat's bought this black bread bread
and her tea and no fruits and the water
was cold and it was very adventurous but
really totally totally different and it
took very long to get kind of used to
that and to accept it and not as yeah
that was not very easy and this for me
is a very interesting point I suspect in
your biography because because when you
came to live in Germany inevitably you
must in some senses have been an
outsider and I wonder if that has has
contributed to you being the kind of
person which you self-evidently are who
is you know going to do battle to break
a lands for people who are perceived as
Outsiders in society
I'm sure that's kind of true in India we
were already different because we're my
skin wasn't that dark and in Germany I
was dark but I experienced that it
sometimes really hurt also but it didn't
get me in my real inside power it
couldn't break me he was stronger yeah
and I was but I was always interested I
try to find out why do they feel bad now
why did we do do that and why is it
different and when talking with my
colleagues with Down syndrome I don't
think I can solve their problems but I
can give them the feeling to take care
of themselves that's what everyone has
to do in life yeah and feel powerful and
say come on be proud and you're a person
and you're going to manage that I
believe in you that's what I tell them
and that makes very strong it's the best
steak that anybody can say to anybody
else I believe in you we know the the
the we also had a guest here recently on
talking Germany who she sat opposite me
and she said that her mother had given
her the feeling that she could in life
be fearless yeah she needed not to fear
anything yes that was the best thing
that a parent can teach a child
no okay cachito de Braganza has devoted
so much energy to the organ cost
magazine in the last 15 years as we've
seen but she's also this hasn't been
mentioned yet she's in in that time
she's also brought up four kids and she
has on the projects and passions too and
one of them is urban gardening which is
when people get together to take an
often vacant lot and an unused area in a
city and turn it into a green oasis
and that's where I live I live in the
concrete gray of Berlin and I don't do
urban gardening I say you know what that
report tells me is that I'm missing
something yeah tell me what I'm missing
tell me about your urban gardening
project but in Berlin you have got the
concession in gap there so yeah in fact
I was that was that very reason I was
that about two weeks ago nice be there
and drink something eats something and
have fun that's good that's supporting
the project and we are trying to start
something similar in born in an old area
in the center and Kazan and the military
form a military base
yes a very old-fashioned building and we
have building boxes out of wood and
planting flan a plants inside already 50
60 real big boxes and experiencing the
growing of the plants and the vegetables
and the flowers and working together and
I have got a big box with these compost
Vilma how would you translate I'm really
glad that you introduced it was gonna be
my next question
compost worms your interwork yeah I love
them because they are fantastic they
they get our fruit the apple cops and
vegetables and so on and create real
fantastic new earth we use it we use for
the our big boxes so it's a kind of Chi
Slava cycle yeah that's so fantastic I
love cycles as you have maybe already
realized I love them yeah I I put the
words born and urban gardening into a
well-known search engine and I got like
a 90,000 mm-hmm yeah answers as it were
yeah and I wondered is this the Internet
just the way the internet works that
you're all you know you'll get a lot of
responses or or or is it something to do
with bond is Bonners you know a place
where there's lots of urban no no no
it's starting it's just getting going
yeah yeah
getting going and their idea is starting
to blow up now and a lot of people are
doing it but I think 90,000 sounds a lot
yeah
but maybe it yet made looked into the
future yeah when we mentioned bond you
I've heard you speaking about bond and
wanted to have the interviews you've
given in the past and you've sort of you
I mean I I like bond I like bond very
much as a city it's you know it's on the
River Rhine and it's it's a medium-sized
city but you have been quoted as saying
that you've sort of ended up there and
it's okay yeah and you've also been
quoted as saying that that you would
really like to have stayed in scientific
research it's not the way it's happened
in your life that you know chance has
taken you in a different direction do
you have the feeling that the god of
chance that the god of you know fortune
has been good to you yes definitely
I think it doesn't make sense to want to
force and plan everything you have an
idea I wanted to if I wouldn't have had
children I would have done this and that
so doing things you can do some things
without children go into Africa and
search for some kind of animals or
whatever as having study biology but my
I had different chances and I took a
different route and I was I had a lot of
luck I think that's true just tell me
about one more because this lady is
absolutely amazing she has so many
different projects and one of them is
called her it's got absolutely
remarkable name the torte intense cafe
the the death dance cafe yeah what in
English it is known in the area where
people speak English death coffee but
that's cancer
Cuffy your cafe and people meet and talk
about death and dying and everything
concerned you know some people don't
like talk about that topic you say it's
a taboo and don't want to talk about it
the others don't want to talk about it
at the moment because maybe they've just
lost someone and the third group it's a
group no one talks about they are
interested in that topic and they want
to talk with other people and
they meet in a cafe in an area where no
one lives but you can just talk to
someone you don't know and maybe talk
about what are you afraid of what are
you expecting do you think it's okay and
whatever a lot of things and they meet
and they're kind of pop-up cafes and
they meet people you don't know and it's
for about two hours time you have
something to drink and eat and every
kind everyone can come there you don't
have to pay that's very important and it
helps you because you don't kind of
stuff this topic away but you know it's
there and it belongs to life and you can
also handle it by yourself and I've
started that I'm interested in this
topic but also because I want to know
how my friends what they maybe want what
they need what they expect when they die
because in the next 10 20 30 years some
of my people are going to die and I want
to be able to support them Mesa I really
know he wants to hear this music at his
funeral and he never once hear that and
because at that moment you won't ask
anymore I want to be kind of prepared
and I'm starting to learn Doodle Zach
now really how do you call that in
English Jack pie yeah because I want to
learn one song and to be able to play
that at the funeral and someone already
told me you don't learn this song and
because that's last present you can give
to someone because I can't sing that
very well but maybe I hope I'll get this
back pipe music thing project managed
fascinating wonderful interesting person
you are yeah well from talking
affirmatively about death and and and
and bagpipes we're going to move on to
the traditional talking Germany quiz at
the end of the show yeah lighten the
mood just a bit has your life been more
by accident or more by design accident I
thought so
are you an insider or an outsider
insider do you prefer to hear the answer
yes or no do you prefer to hear the
answer yes or no yes
is Germany an inclusive society or an
exclusive society exclusive okay okay
we've had so many things that we've
talked about today it's been really
really fascinating but it is too tight
that's all the time we have now for
talking Germany this time around
cachito Berg answer our guests if you've
enjoyed our company as much as I have
come back next week until then bye bye